débutant le deuxième session plénière
consacrée à des accords une question de
la sécurité dans les régions de l'asie
et du pacifique et chers collègues
aujourd'hui nous témoignons le
renforcement de l'importance de la
région de l'asie pacifique et non
seulement dans le domaine économique et
de l'industrie mais aussi dans le
domaine de la stabilité régionale et
internationale
dans son intervention aujourd'hui
ministre de la défense et l'accusation d
russie général d'armée monsieur chibout
a accentué les problèmes régionaux en
asie et nous a présenté sa vision
détaillée de la situation sécuritaire
dans les régions cette attention
particulière est lié en fait à ceux qui
ont témoigné le renforcement des
processus d'intégration dans les régions
on voit les intérêts des puissances
régionales et mondiales se croiser et se
confronter porte parfois ce qui fait
renforcer le potentiel de conflit du
point de vue militaire on voit croître
la probabilité des incidents de doc
sorte alors les processus que nous
témoignons dans les régions de l'asie du
pacifique leur influence à la stabilité
de sécurité mondiale ce qui rend en plus
intéressants et utiles le discuter la
situation actuelle le contexte actuel
avec les chefs des mystères de défense
et des forces armées des pays de la
région pour trouver les mécanismes de
coopération des forces et renée des pays
de la région pour promouvoir le dialogue
dans le domaine sécuritaire
nous allons aussi profiter de cette
opportunité pour discuter d'autres
missions importantes de notre genre
à recoller avec votre émission que je
présente nos analystes d'aujourd'hui
général en chef
mais non prague le président du conseil
administratif étatique commandant en
chef des forces armées de la république
union yamar amiral higueras kostyukov
chef du pôle a dit guy ritchie du
département général de l'état major
général des forces armées de la
fédération de russie
génial colonel de 25,5 un ministre de la
défense nationale de la république
socialiste du vietnam qui interviendra
en téléconférence à partir du crâne et
monsieur hassanzadeh vice ministre de la
défense de la république maldives
docteur en médecine comme al secrétaire
en chef du ministère la défense de la
république couleurs de bangladesh non
présentera le vidéo enregistrée par la
lysine ministre de la défense ahmad al
sheikh hasina
monsieur sauf deuxième minus défense de
l'état de brunéi darussalam nous
interviendra en téléconférence à partir
de jonny cocker
je tiens à vous rappeler nos horaires
vous avez dix minutes pour votre
intervention
on prévoit de terminer notre travail à
13h30 pour faire une pause déjeuner le
premier intervenant dans le cadre de
notre session plénière
c'est le président du conseil
administratif d'état commandant en chef
des forces armées de la république est
lyon millionnaire général en chef me
nargue fring général en chef est en
fonction à partir du mois de mars de
l'année passée c'est en commandant des
forces armées très expérimenté en ami de
la russie il a plusieurs fois visiter un
autre pays à deux fois participé au
travail de notre conférence
internationale d moscow s'il vous plaît
en général un vol parole
le président mesdames et messieurs chers
participants c'est avec un plaisir
infini que je peux remercier vous tous
participants de la 9e conférence de
moscou sur la sécurité internationale
je souhaite à vous tous la santé de fer
surtout durant ce top ce moment critique
qui est de l'explosion de la pandémie et
du collet de lakovic 19 aujourd'hui je
tiens à discuter a parlé d'une de la
région de l'asie et du pacifique dans le
contexte de la politique globale région
de l'asie-pacifique est très importante
pour le monde entier en vue de sa
situation jeu politique
cette région comprend une entière de
l'économie mondiale et des majeurs flux
maritimes passent à travers sa cette
région en fait plus de 100000 navires
passent al youm en eau à l'océan indien
donc plus de 70000 traversent le détroit
de malacca
ce qui est très important pour les
transports dont le niveau s'élève heures
on crie en milliards de dollars des
etats-unis
80% de transfert mondial maritime du
pétrole passait pourtant dit à travers
ces trois de l'océan indien
y compris le détroit de malacca
tu m'as pouvons affirmer que des centres
[Musique]
d'attraction économiques sont de plus
amples multiples dans notre région et
bien qu'une hainaut dont nous faisons
preuve dans scénario dynamique de
développement
ce ne sont pas des risques à la
stabilité la sécurité qui manque une
forte impulsion économique que subissent
les jeux les pays de l'est région risque
de change l équilibre économique
actuelle a permis mesdames et messieurs
la situation de sécurité stratégique
heures dans les régions de l'est et du
pacifique est encore relations fortes
avec les conditions politiques et même
dans les pays de l'est région le court
la course aux armements entre les
superpuissances la concurrence pour la
sève ressources naturelles lin
criminalité transnationale les épidémies
et les catastrophes naturelles la
dégradation de l'environnement le trafic
de drogue contrebande d armes
développement de ares mode destruction
massive
les quelques problèmes auxquels est
confronté notre région
chaque pays a tenu face à la pandémie de
l'aco vider quelques conférences et
d'économie et à la santé publique
nous avons aussi mettant les à subir les
effets secondaires des technologies
cybernétiques et d'autres technologies
de pointe les menaces traditionnelles et
non conventionnelles à la sécurité sont
créés par les créations des alliances
régionale et à la concurrence accrue
entre ces unions
à l'échelle régionale ces problèmes sont
aussi considérés comme des défis au
développement des pays dans les régions
et des régions en général les efforts
entreprises pour l'intégration
économique y ait deux landais adversaire
stratégique des superpuissances devient
des composants importants qui
conditionne le futur de la région de
l'asie pacifique
l'encouragement de coopération
économique et dans les régions de l'asie
et le pacifique réduira la diversité
entre les pays et soutiendra leur ai
juste âge du processus de globalisation
à ce qui est aussi important dans
domaine de respect des objectifs de
développement durable
or delagnes un autre se la joue à la
nécessité de renforcer la coopération
pour faire face à la chute la pandémie
qu elle de causer de 19 entre le caire
là on trouve qu'ils sont parmi les
problèmes à que doivent être résolus par
les régions de même façon je dois dire
que de nombreux pays du monde y compris
les pays de l'association des nations du
sud-est anase y actuellement roi
subissent une chute et connais bien qui
est liée à la commune et son parfum
crise puisque les peuples de ces pays
sont toujours sujets à une confusion
c'est le temps d'attirer l'attention
parmi les plus particulières alors
j'étais de l'assistance pourra libérer
les gens de cette tourmente un quotidien
pour assurer les gens des éléments il
faut renforcer la production du riz et
puis froment qui sont parmi les éléments
les plus utilisés par
l'humanité contre cela il est temps de
doter la production d'autres types de
produits alimentaires riches en nitrites
if certains pays du monde
on sent confronté un déficiences de
l'eau potable ce qui renforce à
l'importance des mesures prises par des
organes d'état et des organisations
internationales les entend trouver la
meilleure solution pour compenser ces
déficiences d'eau douce et il faut pas
négliger les le rôle de la formation et
de sensibilisation de la population les
échos unido damien potable léa le
gaspillage d'eau douce à peut générer
des menaces à un autre futur à nous tous
nonobstant at cet été chaque fois que
nous envisageons la le futur de la
sécurité dans les régions de l'asie
n'est pacifique il a il faut aussi pions
foire à la confluence des unions en
désignant est régionale a qui sont
parfaites il faut lui l'existence des
différents géopolitique et cette
confrontation entre aléas superpuissance
la promotion des intérêts nationaux et à
l'arme moderne pour contrôler le mer de
chine orientale et el mehraz de chine
méridionale serbe en signal important du
début probable d'une nouvelle et deroff
froide qu'il faut absolument éviter tous
les états indépendants a réalisé leur ce
héros n'était nonobstant des dimensions
de leur territoire national
la force de ses forces armées il est un
os tous te rendre de respecter à sucre
ce but on est tous des prisons dépendant
chers collègues
louette aux efforts pour accélérer la
coopération avec les pays et de l'asie
pacifique en lançant l'initiative à il
s'en tire une route à la chine a connu
une coopération multilatérale avec tous
les pays de la région y compris et le
myanmar
nous sommes liés avec des liens d'amitié
avec la chine mais au contraire un
serpent pays de l'asie-pacifique et de
l'ancien on travaille est repris à créer
la stratégie de grandes du pacifique
alain cias et tampons entre l'océan
indien et pacifique qui se trouve au
centre de la région tous les pays et les
régions doivent opter pour la paix la
stabilité la sécurité et la prospérité
en ce qui concerne les enterrer
idéologie qui est prioritaire pour
certains depuis qu'il participe à la
stratégie et rende pacifique sont
parfois différents mondes
proportionnelle
par rapport aux autres qu'ils puissent
se trouver dans le même ligne at on par
exemple les s allier à occidentales si
danto démontre parfois des différences
en ce qui concerne les normes et les
valeurs qui concerne les intérêts
nationaux ce trait des priorités
stratégiques et il faut respecter le
principe d'éviter toute sorte de
concurrence déloyale qui puisse générer
des le potentiel content quand le
potentiel conflictuel entre malaisien
pays de la région pour terminer je tiens
à souligner que c'est en effet censuré
la stabilité à le calme
il ya le développement équilibré de la
région de l'asie pacifique
on nous tous nous devrons à prévenir
toutes sortes de situations qui or pour
y gérer des conflits ou une
confrontation personnelle
maintenant il faut qu'une rampe lors
sion le processus de renforcement de la
confiance est d'autres types
d'interactions non mais des terres y
compris à la prévention la rétention et
le trip mans et la vaccination contre la
pandémie de la colline de 19 dans les
régions il faut comme le pire de la
pierre angulaire le respect de ces
llorente l'impliquer territoriale et
l'égalité entre les pays nonobstant du
l'étendue du territoire et de la
population
de nombreux témoignages nous démontre à
langer rend ce bon vieux murs des
etarras occidental dans les affaires
intérieures des états se dér en a au nom
de la démocratie les droits de l'homme
l'époque actuelle c'est le temps propice
pour faire face à la mer au lieu de
subir à l' approche unilatérale pour
rechercher la justice et l'égalité la
communauté internationale doit se voir
ce sentiment sincère de justesse et à
garder les valeurs communes pour s'unir
dans 100 ce pont du monde pour aspirer
sur la stabilité et le développement
durable du monde entier avec respect des
lois internationales s'est mis à mal à
déployer ses efforts pour assurer la
politique la politique est l'ex
gouvernement de la ligue nationale pour
la démocratie a ignoré la pratique
démocratique hier en profitant même de
la fraude électorale
tous les événements actuels au myanmar
c'est la tentative de notre gouvernement
actuel de resterait à la sincérité et le
respect des principes démocratiques et
qui n'ont pas été garanti par alex
gouvernement de la ligue nationale pour
la démocratie mais était démontée par
l'ex-gouvernement peut-être les
événements actuels dans ma mère des
enfants peuvent exercer une influence
est particulière à la situation
régionale
mais il faut que nous tous travaillant
ensemble et c'est ensemble que nous
allons aboutir
je le remercie de votre attention
je le remercie de votre intervention en
général pour votre expérience pour votre
vision de la situation aux politiques
dans votre pays
mesdames et messieurs complément
l'agenda j'aimerais passer la parole au
chef de la direction de principal de
l'état major général
l'adjoint au chef de l'état major
général des forces armées de la
fédération de russie
l'amiral leur igor kostkova igor
kostkova une grande expérience dans le
travail et militaires pour les ti qui a
été décoré par la décoration héros de la
fédération de russie décoration la plus
importante de la fédération ici c'est la
mayral c'est à vous la parole
mesdames et messieurs la sitution
contemporaine dans le monde axé m² table
de plus en plus instable ce qui
s'explique par la distribution de
l'impact des influences entre les
centres de force clé
la compétition est la lutte de
compétition plus aigus pour le
leadership et l'accès aux ressources
naturelles à la description par
l'occident du système de la stabilité
stratégique aussi brillant que non
respect de l'équilibré des poids contre
poids mais les terrains politique et on
nous voyons que dans leurs documents les
états unis démontrent leur et non
disponibilité ou dialoguer équitable et
à la ministre actions américaines à
développer les nouvelles approches
conceptuelles et la réalisation de la
stratégie nationale de l'aide pour la
sécurité qui définissent en tant
qu'adversaire géopolitique le plus
important la fédération de russie et au
futur la chine parce que la maison
blanche ne se contente plus et de la
russie en plein développement qui joue
un rôle plus important dans les affaires
internationales
parce que les leaders américains ont
peur que la puissance que deux
la république populaire de chine qui
devient de plus en plus puissante et
capable vert de mes 32 dépassé les états
unis pour les indicateurs économiques
nous voyons que cette approché
américaine pleinement se démontre dans
l'asie le pacifique et qui devions le
moteur de l'économie nationale est
passée que à la communauté de
reconnaissance américaine mia préparer
un pronostic de développement de la
situation géopolitique à moyen terme qui
s'appelle à les tendances globales 2040
houleuse îles pacifiques et considère en
tant que marraine de compétition des
grandes puissances
c'est pour cette raison les etats unis
visent à assurer le contrôle pour cette
région du monde qui produit plus de 60%
du gdp consomment plus de 40 % du
commerce mondial pour cette raison
l'asie le pacifique est visé par le
washington depuis 2000 19 depuis le
concept de la région m2 pacifique au
vert et libre qui nous voyons que le
fond de cette stratégie se concentre sur
la mise en place d'une nouvelle
architecture de la sécurité collective
fondé sur la domination américaine et le
réseau des unions militaro-politique
contrôlée par washington
sans la participation du héros de la
russie et de la chine
en même temps les etats unis se donnent
les pouvoirs en tant que concepteur
développeur des règles et non de
comportement dans le cas de cette
architecture et les états de l'asie du
pacifique sont
devon un grand choix est très difficile
souvent à prendre la partie des états
unis et devenir en opposition avec la
russie et la chine se voit agir au
détriment des la pression ni en dépit de
la pression de la maison blanche et être
passible cinq chiots american pense être
raison washington utilise le dialogue a4
utilisé pour cette raison on nous voyons
que ces états unis s'est impliqué à
l'inde dans cette structure parce
qu'autour de ce format les américains
essaient de console et et d'autres pays
dans la région y compris le vietnam
singapour le philippine et et la
nouvelle zélande a même temps les plombs
prévu de l'eucoco alliés de la maison
blanche se fonde sur les positions
existantes et les prétentions de
territoire et la stratégie d action dans
la région de langue du pacifique
développé par le pentagone en 2019 vise
à assurer la suprématie stratégique
quand c'est la reconfiguration
intensification de l'absence d'autres
présence militaire intensification de
l'entraînement de traînement de combat
et pour cette raison les etats-unis ont
déjà créé un groupement des militaires
américains qui compte environ 400 milles
mais les terres américaines et nous
voyons déjà à peu près 200 objets de la
marine à maréis compris plus de 50 base
navale et le porte avions ronald reagan
qui est toujours en passe stationnement
mille permanent au japon en même temps
depuis 2000 vingt ans nous voyons le
déploiement dans l'air
lyon et nous voyons que sur la base
navale andersen
nous voyons permanence entre quatre et
six bombardiers stratégiques b52 b1 b2
et parfois jusqu'à 15 avions porteurs de
l'art nucléaire est le pentagone a
commencé à développer le plan de la mise
en place de la première flotte au
opérationnel dont la responsabilité va
couvrir le bassin maritime de la partie
orientale de l'océan de landes et
d'après le commandement de la marine
américaine
ça permettra de libérer les ressources
de la 7e mari non opérationnels pour
résoudre les tâches primordiales dans la
mer de chine orientale et méridionale
sait bien que intensifier l'activité
mais les terres de l'air chine aussi
bien que de l'asile de l'asie du sud est
est prévu de déployer deux brigades
multi ce faire un premier tri celles qui
seront capables de réaliser des cyber
opérations qui seront dotés des armes de
haute précision de grande portée y
compris des missiles supersoniques à la
porte de jusqu'à 5000 et 500 km et les
prévu de mettre en place les pointes de
stationnement des missiles de moyenne
portée à côté de lille et japonais yu et
nous voyons qu'il a déjà prévu d'équiper
les destroy leur part des nouveaux anti
messi standard ta3 de modification de
haut qui sont capables de faire face aux
cibles balistiques à la porter jusqu'à
1000 km merde 2030 dans l'asie et le
pacifique et les prévu d'intensifier le
confond deux bâtiments qui seront
capables de résoudre les tâches de la
lutte anti missile la partie de 23
jusqu'à 40 unités
en plus il est privé déjà de mettre en
place
et cher est prévu le stora et dans le
cadre de cette activité
washington intensifie la coopération
vecquée tokyo qui crée une cadence
accélérée son propre système de défense
antimissile qui sera techniquement
opérationnel est compatible avec le
segment américain du système antimissile
et globale américaine ne voyons que les
panzers on s est intensifié le nombre
des moyens et des outils que les aider
large et le nombre des états membres
pour les faire impliquer dans le seul
sens au contre les adversaires unique et
nous voyons que et ses activités
commencent à tirer un caractère
anti-russe antichinoises évident et en
particulier cette année à côté de
l'alaska
nous avons vu où les marines américaine
a essayé de réaliser des missions contre
un adversaire pour l'air ou la russie a
été sous-entendu pour empêcher l'accès
entre autres aussi bien que pour
réaliser pour les opérations d' attaque
avec les embarquements et les
départements des commandos marins en
plus nous voyons que les attroupements
et de la marine américaine comme level
and children côté de l'ailé gauche
contemple de 17 et mis les personnes et
des entraînements multinationaux erin
pac où il a été prévu de résoudre une
crise dans cette région où la chine a
été considéré en tant qu'adversaire et
il était 2e prévu d'élargir
l'infrastructure de l'activité
d'entraînement de la marine américaine
et pour ses buts et pour ses missions
pour 2022 était prévu d'investir 2,2
milliards de dollars et environ 23
milliards le pentagone intensifie le
passage des bâtiments de guerre
américains dans la zone de 13000 aux
côtés d un territoire litigieux comme
les îles et les paracels et les
archipels sparte après rapide et depuis
2015 leur intensification augmenté de 10
fours et le nombre de réseaux pour les
incidents éventuels dans la mer de chine
méridionale a augmenté un plus et
laisser d'élargir le nombre des états
participants dans ces litiges de
territoire entre la chine le japon le
vietnam et les philippines
parce qu'il considérait que cette
approche permettra de consolider les
efforts communs dans la lutte avec
washington et sous l'égide de john baden
les dirigeants des états unis pour la
première fois passe à la au cadrage
législative du système de dissuasion de
la république populaire de chine et
l'inde prévoit des mesures de pression
économique sanctionnèrent informatiques
qui sont déjà largement utilisées contre
la chine et pour ses missions mais
maison blanche pense à investir jusqu'à
5 milliards de dollars à l'horizon de
2020 si c'est sous la pression de
washington
la course pour la dissuasion
multilatéral de russie de chine est déjà
prévu dans les décisions du sommet de
l'otan qui se tenir le 14 juin dernier
et c'est surtout la politique des états
unis a forcé la république de corée du
nord a intensifié le potentiel nucléaire
un résultat qui vient ne refuse pas de
l'âne nucléaire basculant constatant que
la seule garantie capable de garantir sa
souveraineté en même temps la situer les
états unis essaient de suivre toujours
sur la liquidation complète irréversible
est contrôlable des programmes
nucléaires et missiles en se posant sur
les monts procédé de pression de
pyongyang
en même temps ils essaient de faire la
pression sur leurs partenaires pour
acquérir le produit de l'ensemble les
tares techniques américain et grâce aux
livraisons de systèmes d'armes du
matériel militaire washington élargie et
les échelles de cette influence et
régionales sans compter de la
sensibilité pour le péquin le problème
du terrebonne à la maison blanche
intensifier sa coopération militaro
technique avec teb et pour lui qu'il est
qu elle est investie dans la période
2016 jusqu'à 2020 pour le montant de 7,7
milliards de dollars
et pendant cette période ce chiffre
global à dépasser 65 milliards de
dollars pour 2020 le
le marché des armes du pacifique de
l'asie est devenue pour la première fois
pour le pentagone et démontrer leur
corps pour 25 milliards de dollars a
dépassé le prochain rien de deux fours
où l'acheteur les acheteurs les plus
importants sont le japon lutte avant la
république de corée l'australie landes
nous pensons que la détermination de
washington à pour l'intensification de
la coopération militaro technique dans
le pacifique de l'asie aussi bien que la
politique de confrontation contre la
russie la chine a aussi bien que la non
dispo l'été américaine de refuser les
mesures de sanction pour privilégier
d'autres formats pour résoudre les
problèmes
mon favori zoo le potentiel de crise
dans le puits et le pacifique d'entre
les régions du monde
parce que pour nous c'est le dialogue
est fondé sur le respect mutuel et
contenus des respect de tous les pc si
non il ya d'autres moyens pour renforcer
la confiance et prévenir les incidents
de jouer dans la semble assurer la
stabilité
ici non il n'y a pas d'autre moyen merci
beaucoup de votre attention
je remercie mon général pour votre
intervention qui nous a pété l'analyse
et détaillée de la situation actuelle de
la région d'asie pacifique
les évaluations des experts russes sont
toujours intéressants pour les pour la
communauté internationale et dont j'ai
passé parole au générique au gré des
profs 25 ministre de la défense
nationale de la république socialiste du
vietnam il
le général conté reviendra en
téléconférence général colgan air et en
commandant expérimenté des airs mais en
partir de 2016 et il a été chef de
l'état-major général de l'armée de la
république est à partir de laverie de
l'année en cours et les en tête de
ministères de la défense
si l'ue plaimont général style parole de
mme michu vos excellentes faire
participants a honte je tiens à
remercier les ministères de la défense
de la fédération de russie et en
personne le général d'armée à saillé
chez vous pour son invitation à
participer à la conférence de moscou sur
la sécurité internationale et c'est la
neuvième conférence qui s'est rassuré la
paix la stabilité et la sécurité dans la
jungle oiseaux que ces connards le monde
entier j'apprécie hautement jeu les
sujets qui ont été proposées par le
comité d'organisation est aujourd'hui
interviendrait sur le sujet de concept
stratégique de ce que je lis régionales
il est très important de parler des
concepts de sécurité régionale en
soulignant notre compréhension de
s'édifier important qu'il faut qu'il
faut faire face en gardant la stabilité
et
1 profitant de l'accord profitant de la
coopération mesdames et messieurs chers
participants entre 1945 l'ordre mondial
a contribué sur la paix et la stabilité
ceux que j'ai vus nulle attendant celui
qui a créé la base pour attendre des
succès dans l'économie mondiale de
nombreux pays dans des régions aussi un
inconnu en élan fort économique et
quillan de vignes temps des venues des
histoires de succès des success-stories
à ce qui a contribué à rendre la région
de l'asie pacifique en locomotive de la
croissance mondiale et en timonier de à
la coopération économique au niveau
régional et pour devenir ensuite en
centre stratégique ex de déchets le
banner devancé les régions qui gardent
des risques dans la stabilité ce qui
vibre avec le problème à globo y compris
et des défis et traditionnelles et non
traditionnelles sécurité c'est voter tel
culte et aboutiront territoriale à la
prolifération d'armes à 2002 destruction
massif des conflits en critiquant le
concours professionnel
c'était un risque à la sécurité
cybernétique à des catastrophes
naturelles question souligne qu'à partir
de l'an 2000 francs et jusqu'aujourd'hui
teuhpu le monde entier
c'est face à une menace sans précédent
liée à la pandémie de la police 19 le
surgissement de ces nouveaux défis nous
fait
accentuer nos efforts y compris en diola
gant à de multiples niveaux des
mécanismes à régional jeune homme alors
dans le domaine de la défense jeu du je
tiens à souligner les mécanismes sous
l'égide de la fia commun la comme les
réunions des ministres de la défense de
l'ancien avec des partenaires ce qui est
appelé à des même plus
cette structure créée récemment
largement contribué à renforcer la paix
la stabilité dans les régions
mesdames et messieurs il ya presque cent
ans que la seconde guerre mondiale a
pris se font humilier t n'oubliera
jamais les pertes et les tourmentes de
la période et l'union soviétique
désignera nita qui est subitement et
pertes les plus importantes
personne ne peut nier la contribution de
l'armée soviétique a et du peuple
soviétique à la victoire du facisme où
notre pays votre pays a joué le rôle
primordial fit namco mode d'autres pays
de l'insea apprécie hautement la
participation active et responsable de
la fédération de russie mécanisme ad
réunion des ministres de la défense de
lancia des partenaires à des même plus
nos impressions nomination par à la
fédération de russie des jeux mais des
internationales d'autres manifestations
pratiques qui contribuent à renforcer la
compréhension et la confiance entre
leurs armes et j'y trouve des
témoignages c'est à ce que la russie est
de plus en plus active a renforcé son
rôle dans les régions d'asie le crucifix
qu'1 2 une un aspirant au développement
ultérieur de la coopération et
renforcement de l'amitié avec les pib en
sept ans en facteur actif avec cette
association pour soutenir et renforcer
l'équilibré dans la région de notre côté
dynamo continue à réaliser la politique
de protéger à son caractère paisible et
son autodéfense nous le ton pour
résoudre tous les différends et litiges
y compris celle du maire de chimie
rillieux de méridionale par des voies
pacifiques en oisans à au droit
international et des règles existent en
vigueur dans la région
nous sommes actifs à élise et notre
coopération avec d'autres pays dans la
russie pour protéger et se mumure
paisible stable à 6 propice pour le
développement du pays qui a la vie du
peuple en me basant ses expériences ce
que notre pays a payé de 2 200 de son
peuple
je devrai firme à notre volonté à
garantir le p ar nos peuples
je souhaite qu'on sente et je remercie
de votre attention je vous remercie mon
général de rotrand perdant sion très
intéressante qui nous a présenté l'état
actuel les perspectives de la stabilité
dans les régions
maintenant j'ai pas ses paroles et
musique à 5000 le vice-ministre bout de
la défense de la république motive
messieurs a mis à travailler au
ministère de tourisme de la santé
publique
et là aussi travaillé au comité national
pour la réalisation des omd retombées
des catastrophes naturelles
s'il vous plaît messieurs vie smith
travel parole
merci monsieur le président vos
excellences mesdames et messieurs
mes collègues et moi nous sommes
reconnaissants pour votre intervention
et je tiens à vous passer nos
salutations les plus sincères de la part
du gouvernement et du peuple de mon pays
que nous adressons au gouvernement et au
peuple russes de la part du président de
la république qui est la part du
ministre de la défense de notre pays
je tiens à remercier son excellence
ministre de la défense de la fédération
russe c'est général de l'armée ces
lanceurs sérieux chez vous pour 15
années qui nous a été adressé je tiens à
souligner général famine pour une
réception qui nous a été réservé réservé
hier pour l'accueil qui nous a été
réservé hier tels que les conflits la
conférence de moscou sur la sécurité
internationale est organisée durant une
période importante pour l'histoire
mondiale à la pandémie de la commune de
19 ans renversé le monde entier à partir
de l'année passée la région de
l'asie-pacifique habite 60% de la
population mondiale représente une
région avec une diversité exemplaires il
est très important pour nous d'assurer
la sécurité pour le monde
pour les régions nous pouvons donner de
différentes définitions à la stabilité
et la sécurité
mais l'essentiel c'est ce sentiment qui
doit être propre aux gens ce sentiment
de confiance dans l'avenir
ce qui ne fait pas face à des multiples
risques les autres des problèmes par
exemple les dans l'armée le remplacement
de 2 du capital humain par
l'intelligence artificielle
comme vous n'êtes pas sans savoir le
milliard de ces dispositifs peuvent être
connectés à l'internet en mouvement dès
maintenant la concernant dans l'espace
cybernétique ont fait en nouveau champ
de bataille
ces défis sont de plus en plus à notre
époque de fausses actualité et de la
politique médiatique il est important de
générer de nouvelles approches d'abord
maîtriser ses campagnes de propagande a
été de désinformation la région de
l'asie et du pacifique témoigne la
recrudescence cette menace qui se
manifeste à la violation des processus
existants
la destruction de la structure existante
qui assurent la sécurité
ces effets sont suivis de toute sorte de
campagne en format ticket l'issue de
réseaux sociaux et des médias du monde
entier ce qui est en legends confus ils
ne comprennent plus ce qui se passe ces
hostilités cybernétique vise non
seulement les états il vise les simple
citoyen ordinaire
notre pays est très préoccupée à usage
le plus de plus en plus massif du de
l'espace cybernétique et des médias
actuellement il faut maîtriser non
seulement les problèmes de changement
climatique il faut aussi lutter contre
toutes sortes de crimes de criminalité
dans la région de l'asie-pacifique
[Musique]
voyant le contexte actuel de la sécurité
internationales il nous est clair qu'il
n'est pas possible de se protéger nos
seuls contre la radicalisation et le
terrorisme international
une attaques récentes contre le speaker
d'entre eux parlement a essayé de nous
porter la plaie la plus douloureuse au
coeur de notre pays il faut trouver des
moyens apparaît c'est menace à prévenir
les attaques et comme celle lancèrent
nouvelle demande ne s'agit des
terroristes qui n'ont aucun prétexte aux
justifications religieux ne sont jamais
lié avec le couleur de votre peau ou
votre conscience
les maldives nous sommes dépendants
de la pisciculture et du tourisme toutes
sortes d' attaque terroriste
nous et nos des gardes radicalement la
situation nous pouvons pas permettre que
non citoyen se radicalise
en tombant dans les réseaux des
terroristes à l'internet
il est crucial de définir et d'éradiquer
les causes de ces toutes sortes de
comportements des tournées radicaliser
ce qu'une fée organisé une stratégie
commune pour lutter contre le terrorisme
nous avons créé notre centre
antiterroriste qui est l'agent ce
général de la lutte antiterroriste et
des manifestations d'extrémisme
nous visons le thé le terrorisme en
élaborant un plan particulier de la
lutte contre ce fléau qui donne qui
autorise nos forces armées le cas et
chiant de participer à cette lutte
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut pour que nous
aboutissions à initiatives
antiterroristes
il faut assurer la coopération
internationale d'ensemble et là je tiens
à souligner l'importance d'une mécanisme
en plaisantant sur la sécurité
internationale pour les tipis et les
pays situés sur des îles comme le sont
les motive
aucun pays ne peut se protéger seul
contrebas
guère hybride aucun pays ne peut seul
set face à toutes sortes de menaces et
les défis actuels
j'espère que nos échanges durant ces
deux jours aussi fructueux et nous
aideront à aboutir dans notre cause je
vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
je le remercie pour votre intervention
toujours ce pignon sur la situation
actuelle dans le contexte de nécessité
d'assurer la sécurité maritime dans pays
situés sur les yeux elle est très
important pour nous tous et noah riche
ira cher j'ai passé par le secrétaire en
chef du ministère de la défense des
bangladesh est monsieur kamel représente
le premier ministre et maire de la
défense sur magic à sina sina et une
personnalité ayant une énorme expérience
dans le domaine politique de gestion de
l'état monsieur qui a mal je postais
parole
s'il vous plaît
le président aux excellences mesdames et
messieurs chers participants c'est un
privilège pour moi de m'en tenir aussi à
cette même conférence de moscou sur la
sécurité internationale
c'est avec beaucoup de risques mais une
énorme gratitude
q je me souviens des de l'histoire des
années passées et je me base à des
possibles qui ont été informés par un
crochet cher et casseroles et
d'echirolles de la part de banques le
marché national se nouent et gestion
exprimer notre gratitude au gouvernement
de la fédération de russie pour
l'organisation de cet événement
d'importance dans les regards je suis
persuadé que cette conférence sur 1,13
et nous ensemble nous serons élaborer
des solutions pour résoudre de
différents problèmes qui menace la
sécurité la stabilité mondiale
maintenant mesdames et messieurs je
tiens à attirer votre attention au
discours de madame cheikh hasina qui
poursuivra notre intervention de la
parole
au nom de dieu
vous êtes curieux et clément mesdames et
messieurs c'est avec un grand plaisir
que je chantais revient à la conférence
consacrée à la sécurité internationale
je tiens à remercier le gouvernement de
la fédération de russie pour
l'organisation de cet événement j'espère
que cette conférence et nous aidera à
surmonter les problèmes les plus épineux
de l'actualité le monde et la stabilité
ne peuvent pas renier sans notre
victoire à sur la pauvreté sans qu'une
eau seront assurées de bonnes conditions
pour la ville de le demander les gens au
bangladesh est devenu indépendant en
1971 et notre pays
vrai toujours pour assurer la stabilité
et la paix pour cette population bomb et
je respecte les principes de l'amitié
allahyar de tout de tous les pays nous
sommes une démocratie nous aimons la
paix et à bong la dèche et nous essayons
de résoudre toutes sortes de problèmes
de conflits régionaux
pas une fois un paisible parce que nous
savons ce douleur de perdre les gens qui
nous sont proches
nous avons connu tous ces pertes de ses
pertes
durant notre accession à l'indépendance
dans ce pays joue un rôle important pour
sur la pause la paix nous participons du
façon active aux opérations de l'onu
visant le maintien de la paix nous
venons très bien de ce qu les pays de
son cv tic en fait pour nous l'union
soviétique non en souvenons de ce
soutien qui nous ait été accordée par
l'union soviétique après notre accession
à l'indépendance en 1971 serait
bangladesh aujourd'hui c'est à une
maison temporaire pour plus d'un million
d a bien marché qui représente en grand
danger pour bangladesh heures dans le
domaine de sécurité parce qu'il est très
compliqué de servir de maison pour une
population à si grande
alors je m'adresse encore une fois à la
communauté internationale pour assurer
le rapatriement de ses camarades qui eux
doivent rejoindre leurs proches
le point suivant c'est coville de 19 et
la pandémie actuelle ce qui représente
un défi est parmi les plus importants de
l'époque ce virus
le cif qui a influencé beaucoup la
situation économique des pays et
remporté de multiples vies humaines
mon état mon gouvernement a déjà su
assurer la stabilité et durant la lutte
contre cette pandémie et entreprises
toute ethnie les initiatives toutes les
mesures nécessaires dans de multiples
secteurs
nous sommes pour la vaccination et
honorer les ans la vaccination gratuite
de notre population sont ouverts à
toutes les sources du vaccin
notre gouvernement travaille avec le
gouvernement russe pour les réceptions
du accent russe
et bong a déjà des kiss-in ya des
possibilités a le potentiel pour
fabriquer du mox en haut nous voulons
intégrer ce circuit de fabrication le
promotion qui est très importante pour
nos concerne le champ thématique
bangladesh et parmi les
victime de ces changements climatiques
nous ne contribuons pas la dégradation
de la situation et nous espérons que la
communauté internationale jouera le rôle
proactif en proposant des voix de
résoudre ce problème à travers la
coopération et à l'implication de toutes
les parties présentes
chers collègues il est évident que nous
pouvons dire mais sans qu'un problème
actuel dans le même sécurité comporte de
multiples facettes dont l'une est le
déplacement forcé des des personnes
ce déplacement forcé représente une mine
à sa part toute particulière sans
omettre le séparatisme et l'extrémisme a
les larmes de détruire massif la
criminalité cybernétique des problèmes
écologiques
tous ces défis forme ont eu de problème
qui est de nature compromettre la
stabilité internationale la sécurité du
monde
cher participants de conférences et
j'espère que votre travail permettra de
générer des solutions à des problèmes à
qui et sape la sécurité internationales
j'espère que israël et les palestiniens
vont résoudre leurs conflits aussi bien
que d'autres participants d'autres
conflits qui n'est qu sont nombreux par
le monde
en dix ans pour conclure j'ai souligné
plusieurs points tout d'abord il faut
vacciner tout le monde pour lutter
contre la commune
secundo il faut à présenter de l'est de
manière à les plus démunis à ce
troisième point le rapatriement de tous
les biens mer ce qui sont sur le
territoire de bangladesh
tout ça ne peut être fait qu'en
renforçant la coopération internationale
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup je vous remercie
maintenant j'aimerais vous demander de
transmettre à madame la premier ministre
pour sa déclaration sans message très
riche et un conclusion j'aimerais donner
la parole et la possibilité aux
messieurs au chaud car bio sera le
deuxième est secrétaire de défense de
l'état brawn et dar salam qui va
participer à depuis la capitale de
brunet en visioconférence passé que a
par le passé c'est un général commandant
mais il était très très très expérimenté
qui a servi pendant plus de 30 ans dans
les forces armées et en janvier 2018 et
elle a occupé le poste actuel cette
année monsieur lui sont offertes préside
le conseil des ministres de défense
partenaires du dialogue clé des
ministères de défense dans la région
l'asie le pacifique là messieurs les
ministres c'est à vous la parole merci
merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs chers participons
la conférence bonjour à tous ou
embauches dans la fonction ou de la
noise est d'abord j'aimerais remercier
de la possibilité de participer à la 9e
conférence de moscou sur la sécurité
internationale
pour moi c'est un grand honneur de
participer à cette conférence pour la
première fois
sauf que je le fais on forme à dire suel
en plus j'aimerais féliciter le ministre
de défense russe pour l'organisation de
cette conférence
malgré les conditions compliquent il y
aussi 19 et sa pandémie
j'espère parce que dans les plus brefs
délais je pourrais revenir à moscou
physiquement chers messieurs les
ministres mesdames et messieurs chers
participants nous notre pays cette année
félicite le 30e anniversaire des
relations entre l'ancienne et la russie
chez nous félicitons le renforcement du
dialogue entre ancien et il a réussi
pendant les dernières décennies la
russie a été une autre partenaire très
fiable est très fort en parlant de
relation entre la russie et les anciens
parce qu'il nous a toujours soutenus
dans le cas dans notre dialogue
nous coopérons dans différents domaines
comme la politique l'économie la culture
et d'autres domaines
qui d'autre coopération dans le domaine
de la sécurité
nous renforçons le dialogue et nos
échanges des visites et des rencontres
bilatérales
et bien sûr je pourrais citer le feu
rendent régionales cela sert et d'autres
événements sous son égide
notre dialogue continue à s'enrichir et
à s'intensifier et en avril et 2 mai 16
avons remarqué une rencontre extrêmement
important entre les représentants ceux
de russie et lanceurs et surtout les
hauts dirigeants de russie le dialogue
là des mêmes plus est un facteur très
important de notre coopération
abbas cocker honte à l'inde
nous avons vu l'apparition de nouvelles
initiatives est très importante en plus
nous avons de travail qui continuait à
fonctionner dans la perte de 2018
jusqu'à 2020 sur différents problèmes
humanitaires
actuellement la russie occupe la place
de l'expert au sein de ces groupes poule
lutter contre le terrorisme et la sai et
la russie continue la coopération
étroite dans la lutte contre les
criminels étaient et nationale aussi
bien que transfrontières et nous avons
mis en place un groupe spécifique sur
ces questions pour lutter contre le
terrorisme transfrontalière dont nous
intensifions impermanence notre
potentiel et nous voyons les résultats
pratiques de ce travail entre nous et la
conférence de moscou
pour la sécurité internationale est
encore un exemple des événements qui
nous permet dans l'ambiance de confiance
bilatérale d'acquérir et d'avoir des
résultats concrets nous pourrons
échanger des idées sur les questions les
plus vitales en comprenons c'est en
effet au futur sur la résolution de
problèmes pour les tickets se communique
surtout sur le fond ne la lutte contre
le coc vide 19 dans le cadre de la
pandémie actuelle parce que les
situations se contemple est absolument
imprévisibles comme les situations
internationales qui n'est pas stable du
tour bien sûr ça va faire un impact sur
notre pays occidentaux sur la région
l'asie le pc fixes et les défis
deviennent de plus en plus complexes
d'environ de même il faut maintenir
toujours le progrès dans nos relations
pendant les deux dernières années le
caractère ambigu imprévisible à cause de
covin de l'excrétion internationale et
pour d'autres raisons s'est aggravée
possède présence est extrêmement
important d'intensifier les potentiels
de ses relations pour faire face
ensemble à tous ces défis y compris des
phénomènes climatiques et bien sûr les
acquis et technologiques pourraient nous
aider là dessus nous pourrions utiliser
différents types de modèles étaient pour
résoudre les problèmes actuels
bien sûr en respectant les intérêts des
uns et des autres et les tendances
technologiques en même temps puisse
avoir des impacts négatifs et fragiliser
la vulnérabilité passé quand je me
réfère lapsus sur la cybercriminalité et
sureau le cyber espace qui pourrait
cacher une menace globale parce que les
cyberattaques les cybercrimes avant nous
n'avons même pas pu nous imaginer que ça
va faire partie des parts dans notre vie
et notre pays de monnaies d'arrossa
large et un pays qui aime la paix et ne
sont nourris une conspiration étroite
avec nos partenaires régionaux aussi
bien qu'avec nos amis internationaux
chers messieurs les ministres mesdames
les ministres je préside lancé à cette
année et je veux rond pour assurer que
nous continuerons le travail visant à
renforcer la paix non voulons pouvoir et
continuer un travail efficace afin
d'assurer la prospérité de notre région
est selon nous faisons ensemble nous
serons capables d'atteindre tous les
résultats parce que là ça c'est une
grande famille et ensemble nous pouvons
attirer de futurs processeurs pour nous
tous alain seul atteint grand intérêt
d'intensifier les relations avec ses
partenaires en dehors de cette région
nous nous parlons
de l'approché multilatérale parce que
tous ses as roches vont contribuer à la
stabilité à la paix dans cette région
shiren mesdames et messieurs les
ministres la diplomatie c'est donc déjà
nous qui me permet de résoudre
extrêmement importante que la haute
direction de l'ancien puits s'est
rencontré dans le cadre de la des mêmes
puces et dans d'autres formats pour que
cette coopération pratique yens résulte
en coopération active surtout un
particulier dans le secteur militaire
nous voyons le soutien de la part de
russie et d'autres états membres de
l'ademe est même plus une grâce à cette
coopération pratique nous donnons plus
riche au niveau des connaissances
pratiques surtout grâce au travail d'un
groupe de travail au sein de notre
organisation nous ne pouvons battre
contre le terrorisme s et es les et
différentes activités humanitaires
le 16 joueurs la semaine dernière nous
avons vu
l'axonaise de l'organisation où les
ministres de défense y compris les
représentants de russie ont échangé de
l'état actuel des choses elle est partie
russe avait montré sa satisfaction du
travail réalisé par le groupe de travail
surtout dans les conditions actuelles de
la pandémie en cours
m nous sommes toujours pour ce que
l'ancien développeur la paix et renforce
l'interaction pratique entre nos états
au sein de la région il est parmi tous
les partenaires chers messieurs et
mesdames les ministres chers partenaires
mesdames et messieurs nous tous
attendons les tableaux de rétablissement
après la disparition de la crise de
commis 19 mai les états ne sont pas
capables de résoudre ce problème tous
seuls dans les conditions qui moi en
tant que le président de l'as hier cette
année je veux souligner ce que nous nous
concentrons sur la coopération avec nos
partenaires nous apprécions surtout la
participation russe
dans le cas de ce dialogue il nous
attendons avec impatience la poursuite
du travail pour échanger les expériences
pour assurer la prospérité dans notre
région de l'asie et le pacifique
merci beaucoup de votre attention
monsieur sort merci beaucoup pour votre
intervention très riche
messieurs mesdames notre session touche
à sa fin mais nous avons reçu des
rapports vidéos qui ont été préparés
d'avancé maintenant je proposais d'
écouter le message du général de l'armée
thein sein montana lattes qui représente
la république démocratique du laos merci
beaucoup
cher monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs tout d'abord j'aimerais vous
exprimer les rôles de remerciement au
ministère de la défense de la fédération
de russie surtout au ministre de la
défense le général d'armée monsieur
servier
ce goût qui invite et moi même
personnellement avec la délégation de
participer à la 9e conférence de moscou
sur la sécurité internationale de lille
20 heures et cet événement une
importance extrême pour plusieurs pays
du monde et sert de l'année de la reine
importantes pour réaliser des
consultations visant à trouver et
chercher de nouveaux accès pour élargir
la coopération afin de promouvoir et
faire face aux défis contemporains dans
le domaine des sicav est il de la
sécurité maintien de la paix surtout ont
participé à la session les défis et
menaces dans la région de l'asie
pacifique
nous voyons que cette menace et la
pandémie giacobbi 19 que devenu
universel pour tous parce qu'ils
continuent à jouer un impact négatif sur
les pays du monde et la demande de nos
produits du monde pour identifier les
processus de recherche des accents pour
la population mais s'est fait peur à ce
corps navires us et le nombre continue à
augmenter et la république populaire et
démocratique de la hausse ainsi indiqué
apprécié et remercie ceux qui ont
élaboré et produit des vaccins quand il
connaît l'heure est surtout sous l'égide
de la nation mondiale de la santé
publique qui favorise différentes formes
de la lutte contre la pandémie du comité
jeunesse et les états membres de
l'association des secteurs de l'asie du
sud-est et en soeur
zaffran comment surfer ou par
l'intermédiaire de la fondation des
médicaments pour lutter contre le colis
19 prévenir l'apparition des situations
d'urgence en asie du sud est
dans le cadre de ce dialogue on adapte
et la déclaration commune des ministres
de la défense de l'association a résulté
en entraînement pratique des partenaires
et des membres de l'asean pour échanger
les expériences entre expenses laisser
ministériel dans la lutte contre le
communisme
mesdames et messieurs chers messieurs
les présidents à ce temps des
technologies informatiques contemporain
qui sont toujours utilisés bien être de
l'humanité quand même nous voyons les
menaces de l'organisation par la
communauté criminelle nous voyons
l'apparition de nouvelles formes parce
que les ordinations te résister puis
savoir l'accès à ces technologies
contemporaines qui puisse faire changer
la stratégie et les formes de leurs
activités illégales
pour cette raison il est extrêmement
important de tresser les neuf et les
menaces et se protéger parce que ça
devient de plus en plus compliqué
surtout en parlant de la cybersécurité
c'est une question pas ça plus du tout
mais quand même nous allons toujours
continuer notre travail dans ce domaine
et bien sûr c'est fait que je viens de
mentionner nécessité interactions
politique qui nécessite de faire face à
ces défis et je pense que les états qui
possèdent cette logique doivent
poursuivre les consultations pour
échanger des mécanismes de coopération
afin d'assurer la sécurité de nos
systèmes informatiques de des
plantations à ce qui concerne la
coopération au sein de l'ancienne nous
avons mis en place le week-end le
dialogue au niveau des ministres de la
défense de lanceur néo concernant
l'activité des ambitions de terroristes
à des changes et les mécanismes de
cette interaction pas ce qu'ils
favorisent l'augmentation de nos
possibilités pour tracer et prévenir ces
menaces et évidemment c'est mécanique
deviendront quelque chose qui vont
prendre nous voit
l'argumentation de nos capacités et
j'espère que nous pourrons faire face
tous ensemble à ces nouvelles menaces
mesdames et messieurs évidemment les
phénomènes naturels reste un obstacle
très sérieux qui résultaient en mort 2
[Musique]
de plusieurs jours et soeurs yes hurle
détriment à la propriété étatique et
personnes dans différents pays du monde
ces derniers temps le laos en commun
avec l'armée populaire de chine organisé
des entraînements bilatéraux visant à
faire face aux résultats et conséquence
des phénomènes naturels
on commet avec les dialogues des
défenses d'autodéfense japonaises ont co
présidé le groupe des experts de travail
de la dé même plus dans le domaine de
l'assistance humanitaire dans la période
de 2014 mais c'est celle de climat
extrêmement important du point de vue de
la régulation et des règlements pour
faire face aux phénomènes naturels ce
processus représente un système outils
latéraux qui favorise heures
l'assistance humanitaire open opportune
efficace et en utilisant l'expérience
cumulée dur en 2021 2022
nous avons passé au déminage mais dans
le cadre de seconde de travail delà des
mêmes plus dur en 2017 2019
nous avons utilisé les potentiels
de notre armée et pour le des ménages de
ces territoires pour échanger ses
expériences en plus nous avons organisé
les entraînements deux choses qui ont
appliqué plus de 100 spécialistes des
états membres de l'ademe plus un
résultat sous la présidence du groupe de
travail nous avons nous vu l'impulsion
qui a été donnée au développement des
relations entre le laos et la russie
les spécialistes de des ménages on était
un bois y y pour être des ménés les
munitions explosives qui reste toujours
sur ces territoires
depuis les guerres et en plus il est
important de mentionner que les
spécialistes ont ont fait l'inspection
en commun ces territoires et j'aimerais
remercier la fédération de russie pour
le cetia à l'armée populaire
démocratique du laos
parce que les spécialistes russes sont
démenés l'un grande partie du territoire
du laos en le rendant habitable parce
que le déminage et le nettoyage de ce
territoire
de minutieuses explosive
une des priorités du gouvernement de la
république du laos chars messieurs les
présidents messieurs et mesdames les
changements géopolitiques la compétition
stratégique et des puissances mondiales
et la complexité des défis contemporains
aussi bien que des menaces
on n'a pas assez direct sur la question
dans le domaine de la sécurité de l'asie
du pacifique pour cette raison il faut
faire appliquer des tous les pays sur
les bases bilatérales et multilatérales
pourraient assurer la prospérité le
bien-être universelle et la république
populaire démocratique du laos salue
l'organisation de la conférence de
moscou selon l'aci cotait 1 terreur
internationale sur la base annuelle et
pour les approcher la fédération de
russie visant à assurer le règlement des
crises de différentes échelles ont bien
être la prospérité universel
et nous serons toujours capable
d'assurer le niveau requis de sécurité
au niveau régional et international
merci beaucoup de votre attention
mesdames et messieurs les interventions
enregistrées du premier ministre et du
ministre de la défense de l'asie je dois
cédric une relation les dirigeants des
ministères de défense pour leurs
interventions qui seront publiées dans
le recueil finale de la conférence
seront publiés sur le site officiel de
notre forum ne termine le travail de
notre deuxième session plénière je
remercie tous les participants et un
particulier les panélistes et sur une
pause je souhaite qu'en bon appétit et
je nous attend tous à 14 heures pour
assister à la troisième session plénière
qui sera consacrée au rôle des
ministères de défense à la lutte contre
la pandémie de l'aco vide